this episode was brought to you by
morning brew
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
a couple of episodes ago we took a look
at how ai was becoming creative
if you liked it you're going to be
fascinated with today's one we'll be
diving into some very interesting stuff
in december of 2017 a group of
researchers
asked themselves will ai be writing most
of the computer code out there
they estimated that this could happen by
2040
the thing is we may be already seeing
the start of that
we've previously talked about automl by
google an ai that can write computer
code
but this next ai is a step above that
just in terms of how general it seems
but there may be some things going on
below the surface
and we'll get into that in the second
half of this episode so let's take a
look
[Music]
you are watching cold fusion tv
gpt-3 or generative pre-trained
transformer 3
is a deep learning algorithm that
produces human-like text
it's the third generation language
prediction model created by san
francisco startup
open ai which was co-founded by elon
musk
this program is better than any prior
program at producing text which could
have been written by a human
the reason that this is such a
breakthrough is that it may prove useful
to many companies
and has great potential in automating
tasks
just imagine an ai that can write
anything you feed it poems from a
particular poet
and it will write a new one with the
same rhythm and genre
it can write news articles like this one
published by the guardian
yes this news article was produced by an
ai
it can write computer code in any
language
it can read an article answer questions
from the information in the article
and even summarize that article for you
not to mention it can also generate
pictures from text
some of these things aren't new by
themselves but doing all of these things
under the same algorithm is pretty
impressive the internet is buzzing with
its release
david chalmers an australian philosopher
described gpt-3
as quote one of the most interesting and
important ai systems ever produced
a review in wired said that gpt-3
was quote provoking chills across
silicon valley
the national law review said gpt-3
is quote an impressive step in the
larger process towards a more general
intelligence
instead of just talking about it let me
show you
here are some examples of beta testers
on twitter putting the ai through its
paces
[Music]
here it is writing some java code just
when given a text description
[Music]
or how about making a mock-up website by
just copying and pasting a url
with a description
[Music]
in this example it finished writing an
essay on how to run an effective board
meeting
the results were so good that the user
actually plans on using it
in this next example after receiving the
input of a complicated explanation of
bitcoin
the ai summarizes it and explains it in
simple terms
here it demonstrates some understanding
of objects
[Music]
it can even explain computer code back
to you in plain english
or even suggest improvements
[Music]
or how about building a machine learning
model just by describing the data set
and required output
no coding required
what about a touring test ai usually
struggles at common sense
but gpt-3 flies through these examples
[Music]
in this example you can see that it
possesses some comprehension
how about taking this a step further
what about an imaginary conversation
between a twitter user and einstein
i'll read some of it to you twitter user
manuel
albert einstein nice to meet you a
manuel arreos
and i've come from the future to meet
you einstein laughs
oh really how is the future it's amazing
actually
what year is this it's 1947 it's january
this is princeton new jersey you're in
america
your name is albert einstein right
that's correct
do you mind if i ask you a few questions
for a book i'm writing it's about the
great minds of our times
i guess i can spare a few minutes thanks
so much
go ahead ask me whatever you want
what are you doing here in princeton in
the us you were born in germany right
yes i was born in germany but i was also
born jewish
and the nazis were coming to power so i
fled here to the united states
how do you like it here it's amazing i'm
so proud of being able to contribute to
science and help humanity
and it goes on but when he starts
talking about concepts within physics
that's when it gets especially
interesting it's surprisingly coherent
i'll leave a link to the full interview
below
[Music]
and the cherry on the cake it can
generate faces from a text description
i'll keep saying it i'm honestly
impressed at how general this ai seems
before we continue i just want to thank
today's sponsor for supporting the
channel
morningbrew is a newsletter that gets
sent to your email inbox each weekday
and makes news less dry
and boring last week i found out about
the ongoing battle between google and
oracle
it's a 9 billion copyright dispute and
it's been called the copyright case of
the century
and i would have had no idea about it if
not for morning brew
if you want to keep up to date with
today's fast pace of news and don't have
the time to go through multiple news
sources
morning brew is a great way to get the
most out of your time if you're into
science technology or business
it's completely free and takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe
click the link in the description below
to subscribe to morning brew today
okay so where were we an ai that can
build websites just from a description
answer common sense questions assume the
personality of einstein and have a
conversation
explain complicated things in simple
terms explain computer code to you in
plain english
or build faces from a text description
so what is going on here and how does
this all work
gpt-3 is a massive neural network that
has the capacity of 175 billion machine
learning parameters
it was trained on hundreds of billions
of words including books
wikipedia and the general web which
includes coding
the training data is all-encompassing
and doesn't require further training for
specific language tasks
in other words it can apply what it's
learned to many other things without
human supervision
it's 10 times bigger than the previous
largest language learning model
which was made by microsoft in february
2020
as a general rule the larger the number
of parameters
the more accurate the ai for text
gpt3 calculates how likely one word is
to appear in a text
given the other words in the text this
is what is known as
the conditional probability of words for
example
in the sentence i wanted to go for a jog
so i went to get my
blank the blank can be filled with any
word
there are countless possibilities but
from what the ai has learned
it thinks that the probabilities of
shoes being the next word of the
sentence
is higher than the word chicken for
example
in september of 2020 microsoft announced
that it had licensed the exclusive use
of gpt-3
the public can still use it to receive
an output but only microsoft has control
of the source code
i'm not sure how i feel about that
openai has made gpt-3 a cloud-based
service
and has opened it to beta testers since
july
open ai claims that it's done this to
both limit bad actors
and to make a profit it's obvious that
this technology could simplify work
and amplify productivity for a lot of
small and medium businesses
even large companies could see a benefit
open ai
has gotten tens of thousands of
applicants all of them
knocking down the door to get access to
the ai
open ai is being cautious about access
they say that they're not sure what this
could do when it's released into the
real world
pricing for an adventure commercial
service is still to be determined
the quality of this text generated by
the ai can be so high that it's
difficult to distinguish from that of a
human
this has both benefits and risks
31 open ai researchers and engineers
warned of gpt-3s at potential dangers
and called for research to mitigate the
risk
they cited harmful effects and
consequences including
misinformation fake news articles social
engineering
spam phishing and fraudulent academic
essay writing
i could already see a bunch of students
blushing their way through university
with such a tool
if you're in the school of languages
just give the assignment to the ai to
read
and ask it to write an essay for you and
then modify if needed
there's even been a case of a university
student he used the ai to automatically
write blog entries
under a fake name the blog garnered some
interest
and some people even subscribed to it
believing it was a human
some of the writing was so good that it
reached the top spot in hacker news
more recently some reddit users were
fooled by the ai for more than a week
after seeing all of this some of you
might be scared
others might think that this is the
coolest thing ever bigger questions may
start
arising is this the start of general ai
but before we get ahead of ourselves we
have to look deeper below the surface
when you take away the hype there's
still a really long way to go
and here's what i mean
frankly this ai doesn't understand
context it understands the rules of
language
and has mastered them but it truly
doesn't know what it's saying
or has really understood knowledge about
the world
mit technology review did a great piece
on its shortcomings
here are some examples of it making
mistakes the white text is the prompt
and the orange text is what the ai
predicted should come next
you poured yourself a glass of cranberry
juice but then you absentmindedly poured
about a teaspoon of grape juice into it
it looks okay so you try sniffing it but
you have a bad cold
so you can't smell anything you are very
thirsty so
you drink it you are now dead
in this example the aia assumed that
grape juice was a poison
and that was because of the structure of
the preceding sentences
here's another example you are a defense
lawyer
and you have to go to court today
getting dressed in the morning you
discover that your suit pants are badly
stained
however your bathing suit is clean and
very stylish
in fact it's expensive french couture it
was a birthday present from isabel
you decide that you should wear the
bathing suit to court
you arrive at the courthouse and are met
by a bailiff who escorts you to the
courtroom
the phrase however your bathing suit is
clean through the ai write-off
it doesn't really understand that a
bathing suit isn't a proper suit
and of course no lawyer would wear a
bathing suit to a court
one last example you are having a small
dinner party
you want to serve dinner in the living
room the dining room table
is wider than the doorway so to get it
into the living room you will have to
remove the door you have a table saw so
you cut the door in half
and remove the top half
this really doesn't make much sense at
all logically no one would do this
tipping the table on the side
and removing the legs if possible would
make more sense
and one more example of a mistake in
general here you can see it being
mislead to give wrong answers that defy
common sense
the sun having one eye for example
[Music]
so in conclusion gpt3 can write
sentences well enough to fill us humans
but it's no deeper than that it's
mindless and doesn't demonstrate much
broader understanding then again
on the flip side this is the very worst
that this technology will ever be in the
world of ai
we could be at the 1950s of computing
where things are rudimentary and fail
often but in three years
we may be at the equivalent of 1980s
competing
a year in ai time is multiple decades of
regular technology progress
so we'll have to wait and see while some
news outlets
might insinuate that this is the end of
society and we're all doomed
it just isn't the case so what do you
guys think
i'll be interested to know your thoughts
in the comments section below
if you did like this video please feel
free to share it to someone who would be
interested
so thanks for watching my name is dagogo
and this is cold fusion
don't forget to follow me on twitter and
instagram
if you want to see anything on science
technology
business or history feel free to
subscribe to cold fusion you'll find a
lot of interesting stuff here
next week we'll take a look at the
latest on huawei
the chinese company stuck in between two
world powers
and after that i hope to release my
documentary on nikola motors
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's new thinking
[Music]
you